eternals is one of Marvel Studios most
ambitious films it's an origin story for
almost a dozen characters and introduces
a ton of Intergalactic lore with so much
setup it's no surprise there are some
things left unanswered these are the
biggest questions we have at the end of
eternals the movie's climax sees the
eternal's joining powers and stopping
the celestial Tiamat from destroying the
Earth after some infighting and
trepidation they all work together and
petrify him just as he's emerging from
the sea it's a happy ending for Humanity
not so much for the eternals who now
have to answer for sabotaging their own
mission but certainly for Humanity right
well happy yes an ending not so much
when the eternals discussed their plan
it was clear that they were only
planning on freezing the celestial it
doesn't seem like that plan changed and
the fact that his body is still
undamaged certainly implies he could
still be alive will the eternals be
there when he breaks free will they find
way to extract him without severely
damaging the planet time will hopefully
tell especially if Humanity isn't deemed
worthy enough once arisham examines the
eternal's memories even if he's dead the
dead that there's still a frozen
Celestial emerging from the planet's
core if nothing else that's going to
ruin more than a few days somewhere in
the world
Dan Whitman only has a handful of scenes
in eternals a small surprise given that
he's portrayed by an actor as prominent
as kit Harrington even so his scenes are
of great narrative and emotional
importance in his final scene before the
credits Dane starts telling Cersei that
his family history was more complicated
than he thought only to be so rudely
interrupted by erishim literally
stealing his girl the post-credits scene
however teases Dane's future we see him
approach a sword only to be asked by an
unseen voice if he wants to do that
Comics fans will at least partly see
where this is going Dane Whitman is the
Black Knight a superhero who wields a
powerful and mystical sword he's often
portrayed as a descendant of the
original Black Knight who appeared in
various Adventure Comics from Marvel
pre-stan Lee he's also the nephew of
another villainous Black Knight and if
the movie stayed true to the comics
that's likely the uncle with whom Cersei
said Dane had a strained relationship
you hear that Sprite family reunion it's
about time Icarus is among the most
thoroughly developed members of the
eternals and in The Ensemble he's
arguably one of the two or three main
characters partly because of this his
future is pregnant with more
possibilities than anyone else on the
team who do you think's gonna lead the
Avengers
that I could lead them
originally hell-bent on releasing the
latent Celestial from Earth's crust his
love of Cersei wins out and he rethinks
his mission when we last see him he's
flying far away from Earth into a star
the obvious question is what next we
didn't see him when erishim came back to
Earth and we didn't see him on the ship
in the post-credits scene he's almost
certainly still out there but where the
two most likely possibilities are that
he informed erisham himself of what
happened likely seeking some kind of
atonement or that he went into hiding
from arisham entirely either way we'll
almost certainly see him again and find
out what happens next early in the movie
Dane asks Cersei the question we've all
had since eternals was announced why did
they stay out of various human conflicts
up to and including the one with Thanos
the answer the eternals were explicitly
instructed not to get involved with any
human Affairs that didn't involve the
deviance okay fair enough that raises
another question what about all that
other interfering they definitely did as
an example we see the eternals protect
the residents of Babylon from the
deviance and it can be inferred that the
walls of Babylon were meant to protect
humans from deviance but the eternals
were far more than mere protection for
the Babylonians they were the most
important and influential beings there
they provided leadership guidance and
entertainment for the comparatively
primitive culture we do eventually find
out that the eternals fight off the
deviants entirely so their Planet will
develop the requisite amount of
intelligent life to incubate a Celestial
this explains some of it like how fastos
developed farming equipment but fastos
didn't know about the true purpose of
the mission until much later if nothing
else surely they would have realized
over the course of centuries that finite
resources often lead to conflict either
way they sure interfered a lot for
people who weren't supposed to interfere
cersei's exact powers are a bit nebulous
but one thing that's clear is that she's
able to manipulate and transform
inanimate matter this mostly takes the
form of changing something's density or
turning one form of matter into another
halfway through the movie She surprises
herself with a new power she somehow
turns a deviant into a tree this is a
major turning point in the movie one
that sets up the climactic attempt to
freeze the celestial it's also never
explained how she got that power at one
point she's asked point blank when it
happened she responds that she doesn't
know in a tone that shows she's clearly
baffled herself at no point in the
film's runtime is it ever explained
exactly how she developed this power or
how long she's had it it's possible that
becoming the leader of the eternals
after ajax's death contributed to it but
that's never mentioned nor explored the
power is plot critical but the reason
she has that power remains a miss
history much to the Chagrin of many
moviegoers and Marvel's PR department
the eternal's post-credits scene was
leaked by a few members of the West
Coast press Harry Styles has joined the
MCU as Eros thanos's handsome and
charismatic brother Marvel tried very
hard to hide this going so far as to cut
both post-credit scenes and the credits
themselves from screenings outside of
the Los Angeles Premiere Eros also known
as Star Fox is far less brutal than his
brother in the comics that's not to say
he's a good guy he's just not a universe
conquering Titan and can alternate
between hero or villain depending on the
story eros's main power besides the
requisite ability to shoot various beams
is that of emotional manipulation he can
form psychic connections with people and
change how they feel there are several
questions here but they all amount to
the same thing what's he going to do in
the MCU will he be the next big villain
will the upcoming She-Hulk on Disney
Plus adapt to the storyline in which he
goes on trial for manipulating women's
feelings perhaps most importantly will
he sing please let him sing
for half of eternals we're led to
believe that the deviants are an evil
alien force that indiscriminately
attacks life on various planets we're
given no reason to doubt that and see
the eternals who were supposedly created
by these celestials to stop the deviants
fight them off over the course of
countless Generations then about halfway
into the movie were thrown a curveball
the celestials created the deviance
first as a way to control environments
with no natural apex predators they only
became bloodthirsty after a flaw in
their design saw them evolve out of
control at least one deviant learns to
talk and confirms this story to the
eternals but that raises the question
what was the flaw this is admittedly
getting into the weeds a bit but
eternals is a movie packed to the gills
with detailed lore will we ever learn
about the deviant's true design or what
went wrong are the deviants themselves
aware of this flaw can it be corrected
given that we haven't seen the last of
the deviants on Earth and have barely
really seen them on any other planets at
all we might find out one day or it'll
never be brought up again place your
bets check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more Looper videos
about your favorite movies and TV shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one